[Music]
on this Thursday night the anxious wait
on the eve of a pivotal pause in Gaza
the worries of relatives of hostages
we've all failed if we don't bring all
the hostages home and why staff from
gaza's largest hospital have been
arrested violent riots erupt in
Ireland's capital What's led to the
unrest the Netherlands turns to the
radical right the anti-immigration
leader who won the most seats
potential perks and problems what buying
the Trans Mountain pipeline could mean
for indigenous
groups global national with Donna FZ
good evening and thanks for joining us
they say the uncertainty is unbearable
the relatives of the hostages held by
Hamas and Gaza are hoping the deal to
release them is real and that 50 of the
more than 200 people held captive by
Hamas will be freed starting tomorrow
nearly 7 weeks after the worst massacre
in Israel's history the deal starts with
a pause in the fighting that's set to
begin at 7:00 a.m. local time then
humanitarian Aid would begin to enter
Gaza and later in the day the first of
the hostages expected to be women and
children would be released in exchange
Palestinian prisoners would be freed
from Israeli
jails until that happens Israel's Siege
on Gaza goes on exact numbers of Deb are
imposs possible to verify but the Hamas
run Health Ministry now says close to
15,000 people have been killed this deal
if it happens would bring the first
pause in Israel's intense assault on
Gaza but there is weariness tonight
Israel warns there could be changes to
the hostage release plan at any minute
Mike Armstrong reports and a warning
some of the images in his story are
distressing as the clock ticks down to
the temporary ceasefire the death toll
continues to move up the Israeli
military says it launched 300 air
strikes on Gaza in the last day
intensifying its pounding of
targets both in the north of the Gaza
Strip where it's told people to move
from and in the South where it's told
people to move too according to
Palestinian media at least 15 were
killed Thursday in
conun this boy says he was in a building
when it was hit he was in the bathroom
fell to the floor and put his hands over
his head
we have just uh finished with all the
communication with all uh parties qari
officials say things are now set for the
temporary paus and fighting starting
Friday morning it was delayed a day when
negotiations hit a snag over the
implementation
plan things were apparently worked out
in meetings that went into the early
morning Hamas officials have now handed
over a list of hostages should be
released Friday afternoon they will be
13 in number all women and uh children
and uh those hostages who are from the
same families will be uh put together
within the same
patch officials are keeping much of the
agreement secret they won't say how many
prisoners Israel will release Friday
it's supposed to be a 3:1 exchange they
also aren't saying much about how the
hostages will be handed over only that
the Red Cross will be involved well
families of the hostages are calling on
the Red Cross to be able to do more they
want it given access to all the hostages
of life is to allow the Red Cross to
visit them and it's a disgrace that this
do not happen and this must
happen now most of the families of the
hostages will still be waiting after the
first 50 are
free Noah aramani is 26 years old all
her family knows is what they've seen in
this video her and her boyfriend being
led Away by Hamas Fighters October
7th she won't be one of the people
handed over but they say they understand
why this is the order it should be her
father says first the children and with
God's help Noah's turn will
come the other major part of this deal
is for Aid it's been piling up in Egypt
there's no specific number of trucks
that will be allowed to enter Gaza but
the Qatari mediators say during the
4-day pause as many as possible will be
moved in and yet they add however many
it is it won't be enough
the need they say is simply too great
right now Donna all right Mike Armstrong
in Jerusalem thank you the Israeli Army
released more evidence which it says
backs up its claim gaza's largest
hospital served as a Hamas Command
Center this IDF video shows another
tunnel the Army says it starts in a
house and runs underneath nearby alifa
hospital the director of alifa and other
medical staff have been arrested and are
being questioned in relation to the
evidence found tonight Israel's military
spoke spokesperson said taking control
of the Gaza Strip is the first stage in
a long war and said the Army is
preparing for the next stages of combat
in the Netherlands a far-right political
leader has won a huge Victory Gert
vard's Freedom Party won the most seats
in the latest election twice as many as
predicted he's been around for a long
time and is known for being
anti-immigrant and anti-islam it's the
first time since World War II that the
largest party in the Netherlands doesn't
come from the liberal center right four
Center left but Builders must look to
his Rivals to form a coalition
government and as Crystal ganing Reports
that could mean leaving some radical
views at the
door in a Land of hardliners and Larger
than Life headline Grabbers gear
Builders is one of The Originals 17
years after forming the Freedom Party
vilder won the most seats in Netherlands
Parliament but to form government he
must work with others I'm I'm very proud
um it's I'm very happy and it it it
brings along a lot of feeling of
responsibility other far-right European
leaders quickly noted his victory
including Fran's Marie Le
Pen of course I welcome this
[Music]
Victory anti-immigration is a common
point for France's national rally party
and builders's Freedom Party vilder said
the Asylum tsunami and migration will be
Cur
he previously called Islam a backward
religion and after leading people in a
chant against Moroccans at a rally in
2014 he was found guilty of hate speech
but no penalty was imposed one of the
first statements that he's made after
the election was that uh uh you know we
have to stay within the bounds of the
Constitution so he recognizes himself
that some of is more extreme
islamophobic positions are
unconstitutional they might be popular
but they would not be able to be enacted
experts say when far-right politicians
get elected they can cause a
gravitational shift in the political
Spectrum over time towards the right
Builders has long advocated for the
Dutch withdrawal from the European Union
and is not in favor of the block of
Nations expanding his position could
affect discussions next month about
Ukraine's membership and funding for its
War efforts opposition has already been
voiced by Hungary and Slovakia countries
also led by far-right
leaders Builders however must focus on
finding friends closer to home and
building a coalition government Crystal
ganing Global News
London the Rainbow Bridge border
crossing between Canada and the US has
reopened and the FBI says it's concluded
its investigation into the vehicle
explosion that triggered a security
scare yesterday two people in that car
died and a US US border officer was
injured initial fears it was terrorism
related were quickly dispelled the FBI
says it's now been turned over to local
police as a traffic investigation
shalima Maharaj
reports this was the scene a day after a
vehicle crashed into a US Customs and
Border Protection checkpoint bursting
into flames upon impact how are you
feeling right
now
I not very good Natalia boyko's husband
and son were on the Rainbow Bridge where
the catastrophic Collision happened
there in Niagara from Ukraine only she
was on the Canadian side but it all went
down I uh stay in my hotel and me me me
call my husband and say Natalia I don't
know when when I come back the FBI has
already concluded its investigation and
now it's in the hands of the Falls
Police Department who are treating this
as a traffic investigation as you can
see some equipment has been brought in
to help dismantle what remains including
that checkpoint Booth two people were
killed in the horrific crash prompting a
swift response from authorities North
and South of the Border it was a real
sad uh real sad scenario husband and
wife four Regional land border crossings
shut down in response have since
reopened we're very sensitive to those
borders having just had them closed
during Co and of course 9/11 is is a
memory but it's not far enough away for
any of us we thought oh my gosh you got
to be kidding not again initially many
feared this was an act of Terror that
was later confirmed not to be the case I
saw a report uh within an hour that
spoke about the fact that the vehicle
was headed um to uh the Thanksgiving Day
Parade in New York City clearly every
video showed the vehicle had headed
Westward toward Canada unless there is
some method to get
from Southern Ontario to New York City
that I'm unaware of that's just
Preposterous nonsense shalima Maharaj
Global News in Quebec more than half a
million public sector workers are in the
midst of a three-day strike Premier
franois Lago said today he is willing to
put more money on the table but only he
says if the unions show more
flexibility
tens of thousands of people were out on
the streets of Montreal in a show of
support for the nearly 570,000 health
education and Social Service workers
picketing across that Province their
unions have rejected a 10.3% salary
increase over 5 years and a one-time
payment of $1,000 to each worker they
want a three-year deal that includes
salary increases tied to the inflation
rate violence on the streets of Dublin
coming
[Music]
up what police say prompted these
riots there were riots on the streets of
Dublin Ireland tonight they broke out
after a knife attack involving five
people three of them children a crowd
chanting anti-immigrant slogans attacked
police and set vehicles on fire Transit
service was suspended hundreds of Riot
police were called in police are
condemning the violence claiming it was
fueled by what they call a hooligan
faction driven by farri
[Music]
ideology some riers smashed windows and
vandalized shops and set fire to a
double decker Transit bus police say
some of their officers were also
attacked but that Dublin City Center is
now calm and officers are continuing to
patrol there is no Terror related
activity are related to any wider
aspects in relation to this matter it
would appear to be a standalone attack
and we need to determine the reasons
behind that police say a man in his 50s
is a person of interest and they're not
looking for anyone else the World Health
Organization has asked China for
information about a mysterious
respiratory illness that's affecting
children in parts of northern China the
agency requested more information about
the nature of the infections as China
braces for its first full winter season
since lifting covid-19 restrictions last
December as Katherine Ward explains
Canadian experts say the move is prudent
and not cause for alarm reports from
China's national Health commission about
an increased number of respiratory
diseases predominantly in children Drew
concern from the World Health
Organization this month and it happened
fast on November 13th the initial
increase in respiratory illness was
reported at a press conference in China
Chinese authorities attributed it to an
uptick in viruses including influenza
RSV and covid-19 eight days later media
began reporting undiagnosed pneumonia in
children in some regions of northern
China and it was unclear if this was a
separate event or part of the overall
increase in respiratory infections the
next day the who made its request for
additional epidemiologic and clinical
information not an unusual request
according to Canadian experts it's very
reasonable as they would in the other
place where there's a cluster of um you
know infections that appear to be
transmissible among a larger group of
people in a teleconference Thursday with
the wh Chinese officials said they did
not detect any unusual or novel diseases
in the country experts say post pandemic
transparency is Paramount it is
absolutely essential that trust that
many people have lost in governments in
government response and also in in
science unfortunately during co uh that
this is regained the world is rather
sensitized to this as we should be and
you know in the case where there is a
new pathogen or an emerging pathogen
that poses a a global Health threat we
need to know as soon as possible so that
we can act as quickly as possible
probably won't be the case here part of
the concern when events like this happen
is that viruses capable of triggering
pandemics typically start with
undiagnosed clusters of respiratory
illness however experts stress it's
important not to spec ulate and the best
course of action is to manage situations
like these by facts alone Katherine Ward
Global News
Toronto an exploding population of
so-called super pigs on the Canadian
prairies is now concerning American
officials the wild pigs have caused
havoc in Alberta Saskatchewan and Mano
Manitoba since 2001 when the market for
wild boore collapsed and some Farmers
set the animals free they are not native
to North America they threaten native
species and cause billions ions of
dollars in damage to crops States like
Minnesota North Dakota and Montana now
say they are taking steps to stop what
they fear could be an invasion of the
pigs the pressure to buy in ahead an
indigenous group lays out its concerns
over the federal government's 35 billion
doll pipeline
expansion Trans Mountain the company
building the long delayed pipeline
expansion from Alberta to BC says the
project is now 95% complete the cost of
it has ballooned to $35 billion and the
federal government still wants to sell
it it's been working to sell stakes in
it to dozens of indigenous groups many
of them have signed on but the benefits
of buying in are being questioned by
others along the Route Nara reports we
have many leaders that fought for our
rights Judy Wilson is from a First
Nation along the Transmountain pipeline
route which she says did not sign an
impact benefit agreement with the
company our
elders uh and past leaders always
cautioned us about these agreements
because Canada as a country has broken
every promise to our first nation's
people Wilson who was chief of that BC
interior First Nation for 16 years says
a project like Trans Mountain puts at
risk not only natural resources but also
an entire way of life
we get everything we need from the land
because we take care of the land the
land will take care of you it's not just
about these small agreements that
they're signing it's about our people
collectively not just our generation but
the ancestors and the generations to
come that's what this is about Trans
Mountain says it has signed 69 Mutual
benefit agreements with 81 indigenous
groups this is a very very valuable
piece of real estate a corridor to the
global
markets the federal government's effort
to sell the pipeline are underway it
involves talks with more than 120
indigenous communities along the Route
stepen Mason heads up the group working
with indigenous Nations to buy a stake
create a generational wealth a pension
fund for those indigenous communities
that own the pipeline but what about the
nearly $35 billion Canada has sunk into
the project
Canada's energy regulator decided it
won't be probing the growing cost
overruns using construction company
contracts or specific invoices from
suppliers it's people taking advantage
of our communities and that they're
under durest to saying oh this is the
only answer no it's not the only answer
Wilson connects the fight against the
pipeline to the impact of colonization
indigenous cultural genocide and the
ferocity of intergenerational trauma you
hear a lot of the Chiefs saying well I'm
just managing poverty so that's what I'm
saying is we're under duress so I see
Trans Mountain equally because the
federal government owns them doing the
same to our people Trans Mountain hopes
to have the pipeline expansion Canada's
only such system transporting oil from
Alberta to here in BC's West Coast
operating in the first quarter of 2024
but engineering difficulties could delay
the completion to the end of the year
Nara Global News
Vancouver tomorrow in part two BC
indigenous community's opposition to the
pipeline expansion's new route through a
sacred site in the chief regretting his
agreement with Trans
Mountain okay then that is global
national for this Thursday I'm Donna
freezen tonight's your Canada is this
white tail jack rabbit in Regina we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at global.com and thanks for
watching bar Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I will see you
again on Monday
[Music]
bye-bye